Lawyer at the Paris Bars,
the instruction of a file for a jobs in tension,
a residence permit,
a work permit,
work permit,
prefecture Application for exceptional eligibility to stay,
1 specific application Foreign workforce platform,
1 application for work authorization,
foreigning platforms,
Audit platforms,
professional activities,
world activities,
the reality of the activity,
she will check the employment contract,
she will check the pay slips,
she will check social declarations and finally she will check criteria.
The absence of a serious conviction in relation to concealed work,
foreign workforce platforms,
1 work permit.